bom forró e jacuzzi eu tenho que comprar
a opel tem que comprar e vender não
tenho ainda positivos para recall no
papel tudo que tá tá bom vamos lá então
ver quanto é que custa o que eu gostei
não isso vamos ver o carrinho e não tá
aí o pessoal ninguém falou nada que seja
muito bem vindo na mais um vídeo e com
vocês podem falar e minha voz está
doente em gozo gosto muito do ele só
hoje eu vi de bom é que vai dizer olha
você consumista hora de dar pra ele está
na minha hora de dar frei ficar pobre de
vez é hoje vamos aproveitar foi fred
china porque como já disse sou viciada
em compras da china eu não estarei aqui
no canal porque achei que não fosse um
conteúdo interessante aqui pra vocês mas
eu fiz dois vídeos nos traz a
recomendação hipótese é duraram por
tanto vamos continuar mas hoje não vou
mostrar as encomendas em se hoje eu vou
fazer aqui as compras com vocês e mais
tarde quando as coisas ficarem em casa e
sim eu mostro isso só pode ser feito
assim né porque não ia comprar as coisas
no futebol que fera para fazer um
videoclipe falei pra vocês porque não
era uniforme
então eu ia poderia portanto nós vamos
fazer aqui as compras junto só ganhou
sozinho sem meu negócio como eu e batons
já como o restaurante também sua alma
nem as melhoras aí nos comentários
aproveitou 50% de desconto na tua
encomenda ok já temos aqui um código de
conduta e 50% a 50% até 18 é muito tapa
muita coisa mas aqui o promoex condição
é válida até 91 euros da compra então se
eu passar o limite eu não vou ter 50% só
quando chegar a 91 no inter 91 europa é
muito pouco daquilo que eu quero testar
o uso portanto
cada código de desconto e eu só vou
comprar eu comprei o meu objetivo é
comprar coisas que eu preciso talvez
coisas que eu não preciso
eu só quero é comprar não leva para lá
ok nós temos aqui então eu escuto vendas
o que nós temos aqui o que é isto o que
frascos que 30 do tatu botão tatu may
campeãs vendem 30 proteto agem como
assim não isso não é nada assegura não
vou comprar aqui nada coisas pra mim eu
não estive na avenina na pista que isso
é que com fogão a gás portal passa a
poder levar para todo o lado custa 25
anos talvez seja bom para fazer uma
série de acampamentos e não sai mais 25
anos acho que é muito eu vou questionar
nem quer saber eu adoro acampar
[Música]
pois não mas eu vou começar agora com
este é o que é isto
meias têm mais títulos aqui se eu
comprar é pra mim eu estava no meu
dinheiro é para mim o dinheiro comprar e
isso não é pra mim mesmo
não vou comprar isso é muito importante
pois meu deus nem fax não está nenhum
cuidado porque vocês compram tech pet do
ric morte ou estiver 511 euros o que vem
aqui dentro cada um como pesca araújo
cartaz hoje e não estou interessado não
gosto de ficar porque é isto tem um
camisa sempre self fez tudo foram o
homem vem cá o chile vem eu vou comprar
vou comprar e não perceber comprar 24
horas
agora disse dizer que era 111 euros
o que nós podemos comprar aqui a
pronúncia estabilidade e fred já tem
muitos só quem tem baixo que vocês
compreendam do que estou vendo aqui eo
que não comprariam daquilo que eu
comprei o que eu quero passar à opinião
e quero ver se o meu nome ao consumismo
e que mal o vosso também mês de blake
rua tem mais no banco
como assim que o contrato assinado pois
assim os chineses não noto eu não quero
nem saber e eu até já que tem o cabelo
há que poupar só pra ficar assim pois é
colher alguma loja coreana sem perceber
o estrago
o teia que flecha 87 euros já vem com
dardos em estoque por um preço estava em
casa
i mas eu quero 37 euros tendo em conta
que ainda vou ter 50% de contemplar
friday portanto eu acho que é
aproveitado eu vou eu quero aqui flash
eu sempre gostei de ser um arquivo flash
que faixa da ponte na minha casa só
minha assaltar a casa a mãe não dá para
fazer nada é só calçar vai provar
encolhe
já num cavalo e eu estávamos mais umas
calças de pijama típica ou eu quero o eu
que acha pa itaqui compra a crédito mais
uma não tem para mim
[Música]
2 a 2 já é porque é isso tem tudo pra
pintar os ventos
como é assim desde os grandes de tudo um
10 mil o que tu vai tu em paulo da
active 8 colocou neto charco neto o
título vai fingir o que é isto
não ninguém tem esse tempo assim mas eu
também né
ninguém é uma quinta propriedade do
banco eu preferi ordem que está mesmo é
não comprar essas coisas não especial
larga e largar essas coisas coisas papel
pra cara sintetel esqueço que estão à
sua espera por um euro
back on line aí é só o tp anel assim não
quero falar não se não quer uma
churrasqueira hora de pesquisar aqui por
coisas que eu realmente quero ficar em
casa que neste caso é uma chuva espera
acabar os dados combinados mas vamos ver
aquilo que eu procurei então uma
churrasqueira muito bem nós temos aqui
uma lanterna para o churrasco quem é
esse mesmo
é isto que eu queria mesa bar batel
grill mike white porta wan kuok uma
churrasqueira portátil está para usar na
mesa o da prova na mão tipo mochila
incrível incrível
espejo de 23 euros só em preto tá no
final da quinta-feira
eu cozinho estamos aqui pra ganhar só um
ep com essa chuva é difícil fazer isso
acho que é muito pouco
não não não não podemos fazer isso
porque não viu o vídeo não tem pessoal
assistam por causa de uma lesão e
assistam o que eu quero muito um
inspirador mas não é inspirador qualquer
eu quero que os aspiradores parece um é
uma bazuca uma pistola sabe eu já vi
muitos deixar venda cata de negócios
portugal mesmo mas é muito carente e 400
e os 300 euros
então vou tentar é isso mesmo ó 140 já
daqui o que é isso mesmo este que vocês
enquanto o aparelho fica a ganhar pois é
só aspirar expira cabelo terra
bom é isso mesmo encontrei um por 53
euros
é isso mesmo eles mesmo qual é a
vantagem dele é que o funciona por vácuo
eu ficar lá dentro daquela caixinha
depois é só tirar o esfor hora eu
funciona sem fios e é só instalar o
posto não fica cá ficar impecável não
custava 800 e de 0 94 não e agora custa
53 se eu vou testar estes vão funcionar
pois o confronto perdedor da europa já
está a adicionar o fininho no consumismo
consumismo a próxima coisa que eu quero
comprar muito aqui pra casa pessoal é
uma máquina de café máquina de café é
que isso isso caputira eu gosto é gosto
muito café porque isso tem tudo a mínima
anual portugal cop maqueta já possuía
uma cápsula documentos o que o fez
dentro levas depois as ditas e que já
sabe que foi produtora nem sei como é
que aquece mais gostar eu quero uma
máquina sério tipo esta kuyt 200 euros
201 europa já não é muito caro é muito
cara já era uma mais barata é isto é
isto breakfest machine uma máquina de
pequeno almoço dá pra fazer desenhos
frango dá pra fazer tosta dá pra aquecer
burrinhos ainda faz café um custo não
vai dar pra fazer que eu fui cada um
falasse seu ovo é muito bom
imaginem um nome do ex o novo chip mas
que saiba quem foi que como aquilo dar
até é bom eu vou comprar estoques 33
euros já destinados no cargo
tempo que os pós a neta o fato é que foi
composta só de tarawih na água não se
fazia tudo e eu vejo que fez o rival a
riva divisão do campeonato carioca
logo que eu peço um café a voz
misteriosa ela só sabe fazer chá café
esqueça ok eu tenho aqui uma muito para
fazer e vamos ver o que saiu
vamos repassar neste contexto joão dado
qualquer instante sem produto para ver
como um preço mais baixo
vamos lá ver esta diz quanto em dez
minutos que nós temos aqui eu já comprei
já comprei isto e mais que nós temos
aqui outro espectador por 21 euros não
não quero isso lula chuvas em que corta
por 13 e 19 85
isso não importa mesmo não passa as
lâminas não existe a procura aqui no
brasil porque assim o que se entregar
não faz nada
esse vídeo comprar o lado consumidor
está em alta seis mesmo mas que pode
comprar aqui mais que isto está para
abrir ovos a isso tira a casca do ovo e
que irá mesmo se eu tenho incrível não
vou comprar essa mãe 90 do comprar já
está destinada à faixa
o informe diz pra fazer outro lado
conforme cruz difícil eu queria isto uma
estrela é fofo é ter o coração falar que
vamos comprar mais eu quero mais o
período for também não quero falar agora
foram 04 também isso tenha manchado os
vendem machado mas chato não estão
ganhar mas que é isto
isso só vamos aproveitar então vamos
comprar coisas estranhas para fazer
vídeos também pregos e outros conteúdos
aqui pro canal vamos lá ver se eu
consigo encontrar ontem brincos cigarro
uma bolsa de uma base legal meu deus o
que é isso
ai meu deus e do papel que nojo início e
nem é tão bem gorda tem um fato de
barata a não só o fato de joão fala aí o
brasil vai ter que sair né
são três baratas não comprar 11 euros 65
centímetros custa 15 euros vão comprar
essa eu quero ter uma barata
eu quero ter tal foi selecionada 15 ou
30 pts procentro de sanita que o fofo
esse é um caso curioso em quintin não
quer saber sobre jogos e suas boas eu
cobrei que está no disco já só comece já
no ir
então é isso é isso mesmo fica por uma
disfarçada
aí é gravar e grevista tem uma cara de
bebê chorão e 36 novas
eu quero eu quero essa cara tá ela vai
fazer um estádio único com esta cara eu
tenho certeza que sentem o gosto dos
recalls 55 euros
eu não vou comprar e jacuzzi fashion foi
o inverso está bem feita do tablet que
atuassem fundo em uma banheira para casa
eu tenho que comprar a opel tem que
comprar isso eu comprarei eu não sei
porque é que vou usar isso mas eu vou
comprar e rosa vai ser incrível tem uma
mãozinha do e ter o que quer isto eu
quero uma linha há mais pleito tem uma
um palhaço e vida eu queria ver o que é
ver a fé de um candeeiro em três dedos
rep
ae
putin collor eu quero muito e cobra
desse mesmo três de ouro agora comprar e
só no máximo essas coisas demoram entre
três semanas ou meses chegaram a cair
portanto quando chegar essa altura eu
vou fazer um vídeo
ganhamos todas as coisas sabe aonde
funciona o anel é que é só mesmo para
comprar mas está sendo incrível aqui tem
já 18 aí temos não existe eu nem sei eu
não fiz os cálculos não sei quanto custa
quantas vai dar mas eu acho que já
passou dos 500 euros
eu acho que sim
os padres também era espiã um sofá por
um euro
eu quero eu quero o que eu quero máquina
de um dos 27 euros eu quero que a europa
sim usá lo mas seus jogos aí eu quero
deixa comprar 33 do mesmo bando sem
querer uma bronca em parceria do ouvido
eu vou comprar é um euro eu vou
acompanhar pessoalmente eu vou comprar
dólares e eu preciso isto precisa de uma
peça só cheguei aqui olha aí olha mas
dois mais 33 seguida por falar em voltar
a se mexer sozinha ou em comprar a marca
no corpo o eco é isso compra não mas
posso comprar ou simplesmente não está
nem esteve já a ficar caro
[Música]
vai o componente explodir disse não ser
fantasma emocional como é que o sigilo
em que não se inscreveram ou eu vou
comprar uns brincos mas essa empresa ok
e não foi agora que é só continuar
enquanto mostram valve subir ou cair
estou surpreso quando todos quantos
casos esta parte do corpo do vídeo
avanços à frente foi só quero comprar os
brindes vocês já sabem é uma surpresa eu
acho que ele já estava em casa cheia de
coisas o trecho eu não sei se eu vou
usar vamos lá então ver quanto é que
custa o que eu gostei não isso aí vamos
ver o carrinho só um preço assim mas não
muito mais muito mais
mas o preço do que rio é que não
estudasse 123 euros já com porte
meu deus ok eu vou ficar aqui um cupão e
vamos ver quanto é qualificado ok eu vou
desfilar aqui ocupa um deus vamos ver
quanto é que vai dar
o outro um desconto de 65 euros muito
bom ainda field cupom de desconto
prefeito então essa compra pessoal vai
ficar em 548 euros
vamos lá fazer chegá ao saber que está
flat foi comprado mas neste vídeo entre
o link próxima edição a sap em um só e
não digo nada só mandei se você escolher
alguma resposta engraçado assim em mim
pra mim no instagram e eu vou lá dar vai
que eu vou partilhar portanto façam isso
que eu quero ver as respostas já sabem
quando espera que o material que
encomendou isso vou fazer um vídeo agora
mostrar que estuda fazer referiu ser o
material não é
eu gastei dinheiro facto não se é útil e
10 só aproveitei também black friday
fiquem vai até a próxima